l' affaire de sorcellerie au sein des
marseillais n'en finit pas de faire
parler
hier soir nous recevions en exclusivité
car l'amour aux candidates au coeur de
la polémique
c'était très stressée de venir sur le
club a été une semaine face elle durant
20 minutes et les revenus sur les
accusations dont elle faisait l'objet
je savais que je faisais quelque chose
de mal mais quand on menace ta famille
qu'est ce qu'on fait si elle reconnaît
avoir enregistré ses notes vocales
la jeune femme affirme les avoir faits
sous la contrainte et avoir été dupés
par une voyante prénommé daniel tauxe
formulées par ce genre de change oui
c'est pas partir si hier soir carla a
donné sa version des faits ce soir
d'année nous donne son droit de réponse
dans tpm p merci d'années peut-être là
merci beaucoup merci c'est devenu avec
votre avocat doit aussi mettre gasperini
merci d'être là toutes les deux
alors depuis deux semaines cette affaire
de sorcellerie
tout le monde en parle c'est devenu un
truc de fou c'est à dire que même ceux
qui ne s'intéressait pas aux marseillais
comme moi voilà moi je maintiens ne
s'est pas tellement cette émission où
d'autres tout le monde s'y intéresse
maintenant et c'est vrai qu'on va
revenir sur toute cette affaire alors
carla hier aient été là carla des
marseillais qui est accusée je rappelle
selon ses accusateurs
elle vous aurait demandé d'user de la
sorcellerie afin de pouvoir être mises
en lumière au programme dans le
programme mais aussi de nuire à d'autres
candidats de télé réalité voilà et déjà
nous a dit hier qu'elle était venu vous
voir pour la première fois à 17 ans elle
nous a dit qu'elle avait cherché voilà
sur google voilà une voyante et qu'elle
était tombée sur ses vraies cette
histoire c'est vrai dans lequel vous
voir pour la première fois 17 ont elles
avaient entre 17 et 18 ans ces accords
de mémoire c'est en 2015
elle n'est pas venue me voir pour la
voyance elle est venue me voir
directement pour des travaux
on appelle ça des travaux à d'accord je
croyais que vous étiez aussi dans le btp
des travaux c'est quoi des travaux pour
que les gens comprennent les travaux ça
peut être
envoûtement des envoûtements retour à
montreuil voilà pourquoi elle se sentait
pas bien dans sa peau elle avait envie
voilà peut-être deux c'est quand même à
titre privé
malgré tout je peux pas dévoiler
d'accord bien sûr fois allez venez me
voir
donc c'est tout à votre honneur c'est
vrai quelles étaient vos relations avec
elle très bonne très bonne très bonne
je n'ai jamais coupé le contact avec
carla elle n'a jamais coupé le contact
avec moi de 2015
jusqu'en janvier 2021 c'était ma dit que
c'est vous qui nous a dit que c'est vous
qui l'avez rappelé après elles vont
l'avoir
l'adduction je peux apporter les preuves
d'ailleurs que j'ai donné il ya une
enquête 1 comme nous le sommes j'ai une
a4 en cours donc moi j'ai apporté tout
ça à la justice ils les ont je n'ai le
contact n'a jamais été coupé entre moi
et mon ancienne cliente non parce que
vous y avez dit que vous l'aviez au
contact et et qu'elle s'était retrouvé
face à 10 personnes
absolument pas donc ça pour vous c'est
non non d'accord non alors est-ce qu'il
ya eu quand même 7
elles veulent est venu voir la première
fois 17 ont ensuite à l'air venu vous
voir une autre fois non elle est venue
me voir donc en 2015 elle devait avoir
17 18 ans partant de là le contact entre
nous est restée au quotidien tout le
temps ma cliente me solliciter
régulièrement pour faire appel à mes
services voient la preuve que j'ai
ouvertement donné à l' enquête de police
d'accord alors venez vous consulter
auprès régulièrement on peut appeler ça
des consultations d'accord c'était quoi
c'était elle venait me demander des
prestations d'accord combien vous
facturer ses prestations
c'était très aléatoire série les accords
de vous demander quoi dans ces
consultations vous pouvez pas nous dire
non je peux pas parce que ça serait
dévoilée non je peux pas alors le vrai
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui ci est ce
qu'elle vous a pour comment on a pu
arriver à cette histoire de sorcellerie
de sort comment ça se passe en fait
parce que non on n'y croyait pas du tout
à cette histoire donc carla bien vous
voir et elle à dire que vous lui avez
dit que pour pouvoir exaucer des voeux
il fallait qu'elle les formules
absolument pas
on venait me demander des prestations je
peux pas m'étaler sur ses prestations là
parce que je suis quand même tenu malgré
tout même poussé mon ancienne cliente
les gars ce fameux fameuses enquêtes en
cours je peux pas du tout métal et par
rapport à ça mais c'est elle qui venait
me demander
et ça j'en ai les preuves je peux tout
apporté je peux tout justifier c'est
elle qui venait me demander
j'ai besoin que tu me fasses ça ou ça ou
ça donc comme si vous allez voir cyril
un chirurgien esthétique et je veux ça
ça ça ou ça moi j'allais pas j'allais
pas lui dire oui c'est ça ou fait ça
alors parce que là d'anaïs je sais que
vous êtes tenus par le secret
professionnel mais et de l'anc est aussi
un voilà et de l'anc est aussi mais
est-ce que vous avez procédé à la
sorcellerie contre eux des candidats de
télé réalité c'est la question j'ai
procédé à de la sorcellerie j'aime pas
ce terme moi j'en vois quoi bon alors on
au clos quels travaux occultes d'accord
travaux occultes
on est à dire donc c'est des travaux
pour nuire à certaines personnes n'ont
pas forcément faire du bien aussi
on fait pas que du mal dans les travaux
occultes d'accord donc là c'était pour
faire du mal il ya trois magiciens peux
me permettre
tiens c'est ça il ya la blanche la rouge
et le noir y assurer vous même en
déclarations vous avez dit que vous
seriez jamais de la noire de la magie
noire là c'est ce que vous avez fait
visiblement si je peux me permettre
moi personnellement je vais pas en faire
moi tout seul c'est à la demande de mon
client ou de ma cliente
donc moi tout seul je me lève pas un
matin en me disant ok je vais faire ça
sur telle ou telle personne on vient me
demander non mais j'imagine donc vous
l'avez fait site
oui je les fais donc vous l'avez vous
l'avez vous l'avez fait super je peux
voir si tu es sur les candidatures
devient dj wet mal avec votre tatouage
et dans l'est dans les vidéos qu'on a vu
on voit cette main donc la voûte je
suppose d'affaires qui est en train de
planter des clous dont les plis poupée
wings donc ça c'est donc tout à fait un
travail ou un des travaux sur quelqu'un
qu'est ce que vous dites dans le dans la
vidéo ça c'est de la magie noire face et
de se jeter un seau ou c'est faire du
mal mais à la demande
d'accord mais non mais on est bien
d'accord que c'est moi je voulais
comprendre d'où
ces images et qui avait donc mis milito
donc c'est bien votre main c'est moi qui
les ai mis d'accord mais à la demande de
mon client ma cliente d'accord et parce
qu'on n'a pas les outils d'une somme
énorme de 1 million d'années on va
revenir là dessus bien aujourd'hui on a
plein de questions bien sûr pour damner
oui et pourquoi ça a été filmé ça est
parti
voilà alors ces appareils j'ai les
preuves que je peux apporter et
démontrer à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on me
demandait deux films et parce qu'elle
voulait le voir enfin voilà elle voulait
le voir
w preuve oui tout à fait les preuves de
mon travail et ça l'est peut l'attester
je vais bien et physiquement avec vous
là absolument pas adacore dont la
passion lui même pas honte de films
après vous lui donnez la vidéo
complètement 1
alors donc ça vous l'avez fait vous
c'est un travail qu'on vous a demandé
pour vous de votre de vote version c'est
un travail que vous a demandé bien sûr
voilà d'accord donc su formuler des
voeux pour faire des travaux occultes
comme vous le dis oui et donc vous vous
avez donc exercer ces travaux tout mais
est-ce que sur ces travaux que vous avez
exercé vous avez vu qu'il y avait eu des
résultats complètement à d'accord j'ai
eu des résultats donc des des choses
même négatif qui avait été demandée qui
se sont passées mais j'ai pas forcément
cyril envie de parler du des travaux est
négatif je préfère plus parler des
travaux positifs qui ont énormément
fonctionné alors là oui c'est à dire
même pour pour pour carla oui c'est très
positif quant à vous demander d'être est
une des stars du programme ça s'est
réalisé
voilà des choses comme ça mon ancienne
cliente plus elle même tout à fait et
j'ai pareil j'ai des preuves que les
enquêteurs ont sous les yeux où elle me
répond où elle me répond elle même que
ça fonctionne et gilles verdez selon mes
informations d'autres marseillais sont
venus vous voir quand ils ont vu qu'il y
avait ce que vous appelez des résultats
sur carla vous avez ri d'autres clients
parmi les marseillais vous me confirmer
cette information
sans citer les noms j'ai d'autres
clients oui selon mes informations vous
avez réussi à intégrer le groupe
et là où vous selon certaines sources
que j'ai eu au niveau de l' enquête
vous auriez été habile puisque vous
auriez réussi en quelque sorte à monter
les uns contre les autres
absolument donc donc à travailler pour
plusieurs à juguler le sort que vous je
tiens en travaillant pour l'autre alors
qu'est ce que vous faisiez comme type de
prestations pour d'autres marseillais
s'il vous plaît beaucoup de vaillance
oui beaucoup de voyance et de la
réussite
voilà mais la magie noire absolument pas
et qui en est un petit devienne
aujourd'hui démontré que j'ai fait de la
magie noire sur quelqu'un d'autre à la
demande de quelques uns n'ont que pour
carla la magie noire
éventuellement si elle vous le
sollicitez je peux pas citer le nom
parce que je vais pas me mettre en
porte-à-faux d'accord juste on a vu des
séances vous demanderez pourquoi filmer
ces séances alors comme je vous le dit
cyril s'était toujours à la demande de
ma cliente
parce qu'elle avait besoin que je lui
apporte des preuves sur ce qui avait été
fait voilà et ça je le démontre et l'on
vous le faites pas d'habitude je le fais
bien sûr je ne sais pas que pour cette
criante des vidéos qui sont filmés
d'accord mais c'est pas tout le temps
mais aussi par exemple mon client ma
cliente je vais vous expliquer si par
exemple mon client ma cliente est à
distance n'est pas en présentiel avec
moi il a besoin où elle a besoin de
pouvoir avoir la preuve de ces fameux
travaux occultes d'accord voilà alors
selon carla nous à dire que vous
l'auriez escroquerie durant quatre ans
absolument pas pour une somme atteignant
1,2 million d'euros
d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre je
vais revenir sur ça je suis énormément
harceler lyncher sur les réseaux je n'ai
pas du tout menacé ni escroqué personne
je n'ai pas fait tout ça on vient me
demander un service que j'exécute et
après on vient me mettre ça sur le dos
non j'ai une famille j'ai des enfants je
peux pas me permettre
alors c'est 1,2 million d'euros c'est
pas vrai cette somme là exactement c'est
pas ça j'ai pas les chiffres exacts
c'est dans les locaux de mais ça s'en
rapproche
ça peut s'en rapprocher mais le chiffre
exact joué par au diable 2 millions
d'euros d'autres c'est que c'est pas
depuis quatre ans cyril 1 en moi j'ai
rencontré sept personnes en 2015 on est
en 2021
c'est donc deux cent mille euros par an
pas moi qui lui ai demandé un accord
pour vous axez parce qu'elle faisait
appel à beaucoup donc c'est un beagle 2
millions d'euros guy roux genthod ge et
docks et donc la somme déjà est-ce que
l'essor que vous aurez ajouté qu'on vous
auriez demandé de jeter les négatifs
sont extrêmement violent donc déjà vous
est-ce que vous avez une éthique quand
envoyant parce que vous accepter
n'importe quoi de jeter n'importe quel
sort est deuxième question les sommes
qui sont évoquées dont vous dites que
c'est pas un million de mai que ça s'en
rapproche c'est des sommes qui sont
énormes peu de gens les moyens de se
payer ça vous saviez carla avait
beaucoup d'argent est ce que les tarifs
sont un peu à la tête du client
absolument pas pas du tout mais juste
qui justifie qu'on paye un million deux
cent mille euros par exemple mon nom
mais on paye pas comme vous dites un
million deux cent mille euros comme ça
d'un coup enfin il ya des années en
plusieurs fois hmm hmm hmm 3000 euros
senna non non pas du tout non j'ai
couvert expérience sait combien de
séances
c'est pas des séances et c'est par
exemple un rituel qui va durer qui va
durer huit heures c'est combien pour 8
heures voilà comment j'ai envie de voilà
de 3920 3900 euros et celle à tarif fixe
à wii dont ils ont remis leur lit
au fur à mesure de faire de la voyance
moreau nous à dire que vous lui proposez
des factures en plus c'est vrai ça ça
existe des factures chez les voyantes
alors je n'ai jamais proposé de facture
elle me demandait et ça aussi jusqu'à
vous voulez vous payer sur sa société
nous a dit hier non et que vous avez
proposé du coup comme arrangement de lui
produire des factures mais ça pareil je
peux aussi a testée et prouvée les
apporter les preuves et d'ailleurs les
enquêteurs les ont moi je n'ai jamais
proposé ces fameuses facture c'est elle
qui m'a demandé de faire ça justement
par rapport à cette fameuse société et
tous âges et les preuves je peux les
apporter juste il ya aussi il ya eu des
menaces qui avouera répondre aux
accusations de menaces je n'ai jamais
menacé personne
enfin vous voyez mon profil j'ai pas le
profil de quelqu'un qui va menacer qui
que ce soit je n'ai menacé personne à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui et je ne veux pas
continuer à me faire lyncher sur la sur
la place publique comme ça je ne mérite
pas d'être lynché à ce point là sur des
menaces je n'ai jamais menacé personne
majeure britannique et c'est là qu'est
ce qui explique qu'aujourd'hui c'est à
dire ressorte parce que du coup même si
vous êtes effectivement pas dans le cas
d'un d'un chantage que vous avez fait
des prestations voilà c'est très ferme
non bon tant que gérant c'est celle qui
veut qu'aujourd'hui juste qu est ce qui
fait qu est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
cette affaire ressort avec les vidéos
l'épreuve avec avec une instruction
puisqu'il
kate de police a pas d'instructions
paris libéré par une ya une enquête dans
tous les cas ils inquiètent d'accord
pourra pourquoi à votre avis aujourd'hui
cette affaire ressort comme ça moi je
moi je comprends parce qu'il ya une base
et cette base il ya une base et cette
base malheureusement au vu de l' enquête
je ne peux absolument pas vous dévoiler
un truc au dessus alors il ya quelque
chose d'accord il ya quelques jours des
problèmes c'est à dire il ya quoi
quelque chose mais quand on nous dévoile
équipe de quel ordre il ya quelque chose
qui fait que pour moi pas pour moi parce
que les faits sont là on me met la
menace on voit la menace maintenant on
me met la menace l'accusation de la
menace l'accusation de l'extorsion
l'accusation de tout ça parce qu'à la
base d une base et moi je n'ai jamais
fait ça s'il ya des gens qui lisent sur
les réseaux sociaux
je le vois que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vous ont consulté il ya des gens de
la demande et qu'ils ont fait des
placements de produits pour où il y en a
qui vont en fait de la pub mais il y en
a qui ont consulté un vrai fait payer en
est il ya eu quelques prestations chez
vous où vous les avez payé en espèces
les marseillais si ça vous confirmer
cette information
en cache un arrêt pour participer à mon
fils tu dans une très belle villa dans
leurs études que vous auriez ya eu des
ils sont venus chez nous et même en
l'espèce c'est quoi expliquer parce
qu'on comprend rien il ya eu notamment
une soirée vous servez de vitrine pour
dana et voyance je pense qu a pas que
moi qui fais de la pub
j'ai pas dit ça et en guise de
rémunération selon mes informations
vous n'avez pas déclaré ou non plus a
été payée en espèces à l'arrestation
jeudi vers des doigts surtout sans
parler de chantage on envoyait une
capture d'écran d'une conversation entre
un nouveau assistants et carla dans
cette conversation cet assistant est
relativement insistant sur le paiement
justement je vais démontrer juste avant
et digital assistant
êtes vous content ce n'est plus mon
problème il n'y a plus aucun arrangement
possible ni décalé aucun chèque en date
du 13 mai c'est impossible débrouillez
vous faites moi déchets quatre chèques
de 1000 euros 6000 euros 4000 euros à
8000 euros déposée ce jour et
débrouillez vous pour qu'ils soient
payés et cette nuit le 27 avril c'est
relativement assistance et c'est un ton
assez autoritaire est ce que vous l'avez
vraiment
vous voulez vraiment de demander de
payer de cette manière alors je ne sais
pas je peux juste dire s'il vous plaît
je puisse vous donner d'explication
alors un moment donné mon ancienne
cliente m'a fait des chèques impayés que
je peux aussi démontrer donc vous savez
que quand on encaisse un chèque et le
temps qui se rejettent sur le compte il
faut onze jours de valeur sur la banque
donc c'est cheklam eux sont revenus
impayés et j'ai demandé de me faire
payer ce qui m'a été impayés sur
l'entente
alors est-ce que vous avez des factures
de prestations à chaque fois qu'ils ne
voient pas ce que pour 1,2 million
d'euros car il ya des gens qui posent la
question 'qui j'ai des factures bien sûr
donc pour 1,2 million d'euros de facture
de la part des excuses moi j'ai pas
compris c'est bon sur carla il ya des
gens qui posa qu'ils ont qui dit est-ce
que vous avez les factures des
prestations et un vous prédit à chaque
fois des factures pour ses prestations
que je faisais je faisais à chaque fois
des factures à la demande de ma cliente
parce qu'elle en avait besoin et de
restes sur noir en fait c'est pas
déclaré comment ça se passe un ange avec
davy tout est déclarée bien sûr la
guerre donc elle nous a dit qu'elle en
avait eu pour 1,2 million d'euros- ça
c'est la somme est vrai je peux pas vous
parler de cette somme exacte c'est à peu
près ça voilà les ondes et grosso modo
voit là aussi on est à un million cent
s'est séparé wigig vrd vous expliquer il
ya quelque chose au dessus
l'enquète je ne peux pas vous dire est
ce que ce quelque chose au dessus donc
je ne veux pas en travers non mais je
comprends mais d'accord mais on est là
pour discuter
je comprends bien que vous vouliez vous
disculper de l'entente tout à fait mais
est-ce que ce quelque chose au dessus
c'est selon on m'a parlé une bande
organisée 1 à laurent m'a dit on m'a dit
on bataillait jul m'a dit que vous en
auriez été à l'origine mais peut-être
pas parce que les menaces sur carla et
sa famille elles sont réelles des gens
les auront réellement menacée donc vous
nous dites que ça ne vient pas de vous
vous n'avez envoyé personne au domicile
de carla ou de sa famille jamais mais
pas du tout non non non je n'ai pas de
bande organisée je n'ai envoyé personne
menacée car allah ou sa famille et non
personne personne personne je ne parle
pas de ça je ne parle pas quand je vous
dis qu'il ya quelque chose au dessus je
ne parle pas de menace je ne parle pas
de tout ça mais vous parler d'argent
alors c'est quoi ce quelque chose au
dessus de quelque chose qui déclenche
cette enquête
voilà pour être clair je sais pas si
vous n'avez comprendre il ya quelque
chose qui va déclencher cette enquête un
problème d'argent contrôle fiscal
fiscale la vérité c'est que nous on a un
peu arrêté on a tous passé des coups de
fil
ce qu'il semblerait en vérité c'est que
d'accord mais il semblerait que pour
justifier cette sortie d'argent de la
part de carla quelque chose aurait été
mis en place pour ce soit de l'argent et
que cette somme là n'aurait pas été
forcément destiné à vous mais que
c'était une façon de justifier la sortie
du million et quelques voilà ce que
voilà ce qui se dira pas se mentir on
était la même à vendre ses biens si en
tout cas ça se dit mais c'est ainsi que
kkr a reçu des menaces
oui bien sûr un deuxième pareil très
très solide à ma connaissance de
l'enquète c'est extorsion c'est à dire
les enquêteurs veulent savoir loi carle
a été forcée obligé de payer notamment
ouais ça et c'est ce qui est ressorti à
bien ça m'a donné mal apparemment elle a
été oui m gasparini le jeu pardonnez moi
je hier vous aviez quand même car
l'amour ou sur votre plateau vous en
avez pas parlé avec elle notamment
pardon est alors pour le coup moi je
suis tenu au secret professionnel ce qui
n'est pas le cas de ma cliente mais
j'irai pas sur le fond mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que sur cette
problématique
donc vous semblez dire ce soir que tout
le monde à l'information a priori sur
des sommes que je l'avais prévu non mais
en tout cas vos chroniqueurs viennent de
le dire d'après certaines critiques
mais voilà à priori donc vous auriez eu
une information comme quoi des sommes
sûrs et sorties du compte bancaire
c'est comme ça qu'il faut l'appeler de
madame carla moreau pour justifier que
ce soit au niveau professionnel et vous
ne l'avez pas posé la question hier donc
je pense pas que ce soit ma cliente de
répondre à cette crise est là mais non
mais j'en doute bien solide assure la
holding car la mode et parce que carla
apparemment a été victime d'extorsion
absolument mais la deuxième c'est vous
ne répondez pas sur l'extorsion je suis
désolé je vous réponds comment vous
l'expliquez une extorsion
alors que vous avez un contact avec
cette personne depuis 2015 jusqu'à 2021
une personne vous sollicite à distance
comment je peux faire une extorsion avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas à côté d'eux -
lamprière d'être chanteuse mais avec
marley au chantage ça c'est pas de
l'extorsion la dépendance a absolument
pas alors vous je peux tout démontrer
preuves vous pour vous vous êtes d'année
vous êtes complètement innocente vous
êtes sur l'extorsion sur la menace
surtout ce que vous êtes en train de me
dire mais complètement jeu oui je ne
tolérerai pas qu'on puisse me mettre ça
sur le dos je vais tout faire pour tous
démontré d'ailleurs ils ont donc là je
moi j'ai confiance à la justice
j'ai confiance à cette enquête qui est
en cours et voilà j'ai confiance que
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter ce
soir m ou au bout car là
mais que j'ai confiance à la justice et
que et que donne complètement pour la
confiance assaillent quand on vous
écoute tous les deux on a l'impression
tout les deux vous avez été victime vous
êtes ma vie mais à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
moi je me proclame complètement victimes
car là aussi a été victime d'une
extorsion
non cyril neri n'ont alors d'aujourd'hui
je suis menacé
je vous donne mon téléphone je reçois
des menaces de mort toute la journée
j'ai des enfants on trouve mon adresse
jeu
tout ça alors que je n'ai rien fait je
n'ai rien fait est ce que vous comptez
mettre portée pour diffamation puisque
c'est la diffamation alors c'est en
cours de discussion pour être tout à
fait honnête face à une problématique
quand même c'est à dire qu'il ya une
enquête en cours et qu'à un moment donné
on ne peut pas faire tout et n'importe
quoi avec la justice doit faire son
oeuvre aussi sans forcément la parasiter
d'ailleurs jusqu'à présent ma cliente
n'avait pas pris la parole et ce n'est
pas pour rien et pour être transparents
avec vous je me suis entretenu avec un
certain nombre de journalistes y compris
deux chroniqueurs qui pourrait être
autour de cette table et je leur ai
clairement expliqué que quand une
enquête est en cours on a quand même du
mal à venir la parasiter avec des
éléments publics sans vous mais vous
m'avez aussi dit madame que vous
attendiez qu'honorable pour réagir que
j'attendais pardon commis par la sicav
été contrainte d'en parler on voulait
parler à un moment donné le principe du
contradictoire c'est que évidemment ma
cliente viendrait s'exprimer on peut pas
un moment donné laissé une partie
s'exprimer et pas l'autre ce dossier
c'est ce que nous a demandé la chaîne
également tout à fait aimer ce d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui
pardon mais l'enquêté est encore en
cours personne n'a été condamné
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas encore de
décision de justice et la présomption
d'innocence qui est quand même pas un
principe des voiliers doit rester le
maître mot après que ça prenne cette
ampleur je vous avoue que ça me dépasse
1 mais peut-être parce que le projet
voilà ben moi je suis pas habitué je
suis dans mon petit bar aux marseillais